the first person introduces Harrison
Ford hello hi nice to see you again
um John boyega Gwendoline Christie and
Oscar Isaac um hi guys hi hi I just
wanted to say that when JJ asked me to
do this he asked me to not ask questions
that you'd already been asked at your
junkets so I am NOT going to ask
questions that I've seen so um yeah so I
think I think it'll go I think it'll go
well great so my first question is for
you mr. Ford and I asked a similar
question to JJ which is um aren't you
rich why are you doing thank you
it's because it's what I do it's what I
like to do it's what's fun for me and
and I had a chance to work with people
that I really admire doing something
that I thought was going to be fun and
which actually turned out to be fun and
to work with JJ
whose work I had really admired and long
known about and it seemed like a good
idea at the time
Kathleen um I know that we can't really
talk about I can't ask you what's in the
movie can you talk about what's
definitely not in the movie
giorgos definitely not
he walks are not in the movie sorry
that's because Harrison insisted I
barley let's control yeah um
John I'm gonna open this up by the way
it won't just be me talking to you for
five minutes um
you I loved attack the block and you are
poised in my opinion to be an
international heartthrob and soon you
will be a fixture at Victoria Secret
runway shows the Chateau Marmont and my
question is um do you have an attorney
and are you excited about this I have an
attorney yes yes and yes I'm looking to
be rich like Harrison yes I'm trying to
have planes yeah and do all that stuff
absolutely hey Harrison what you agree
okay um my we're gonna open this up to
these guys and I have questions for you
two as well that let's take some
questions from Geralyn mr. Ford could
you just oh right here sorry Zoe
hi could you just talk about what it
means to you to be that one of the
bridges between the original series and
this this new generation ah it's
gratifying to be asked to be part of
this
there was a interesting story to tell
for the through the character it's
always nice to anticipate working in
something that you know people will have
an appetite for this is not a crapshoot
this is
this is big casino and it's fun to play
with these toys again it's been a great
experience
thank you yes miss Kennedy um I guess
this most for you and Jesse I guess how
do you make sure that this installment
make way for what Ryan and Colin are
developing did you guys map out the
whole pre-movie story
oh we haven't mapped out every single
detail yet but obviously everybody's
talking to one another working together
and that collaboration I think is what
is going to guarantee that everybody's
got a say and how we move forward with
this and so far it's going great
I mean JJ and Ryan have already talked
at length because Ryan's about to start
shooting episode 8 these guys are
getting ready to head over in January
and then Colin will start working with
Ryan and and spend a lot of time on the
set with us um Vennela is going to ask
you question uh what character could you
be if you could be any other character
in Star Wars and the reason is for me um
where I think I'd be suited as a singer
in Javas band it just does like a
reference is there anyone else that you
wish or you would think that you think
it's a cool character to play someone
that I would be suited to or just
someone I'd like to play that's an
interesting challenge Oh both that's
tough um a character I don't really
think I would particularly be suited to
but would definitely like to play is of
course Han Solo
you were swagger I think that's a good
finding yeah I might have just like a
modicum a swagger opposed to the Grand
Canyon that's at the end of the south
that's uh that's a nice compliment
crepes John maybe I don't know it's you
I'm grateful for the kind attention of
Iceland a good other question mr. fari
hello from Italy what what is the bigger
difference between these two wars and
the first award does it feel you know
being back on the set for Star Wars ah
what is the difference is that part of
the question you know I think what you
it's hard to say what the difference is
I can tell you how it feels it feels
familiar it feels good it's good to be
home
as is han says in the trailer in the
teaser trailer it's a you know I'm aware
of the value that's placed on these
films by the audience and and I'm
gratified that they've been passed on
the first three have been passed on
generationally through families and that
there's still an audience for those of
us that were in the original film
there's still some value to them in in
interpreting life somehow and it's a and
it's a bit of a mystery but it's a but
it's very gratifying to be part of that
I have a question um what was the
difference in the rap parties between
French movies and this one um it was
really hard to get a drink at the last
rap party wasn't it yeah it was right
Oscar
it was very did hard to get a drink I
didn't know where the bar was it was
just it was so big hi question is for
Harrison Ford um as a parent
hi I'm over here alright alright um as a
parent
what's it like um telling your kids
you're coming back to this franchise did
that like up the cool factor once again
for you with them I don't my kids do not
think I'm cool at all and being in this
movie is not gonna convince them
otherwise I know they're just glad to
see the dad is still working
um Oscar in my experience there's always
one actor on set where everyone goes to
their trailer to listen to music and to
get high I know that none of you guys do
drugs because you're professional this
is a Disney movie it's not Nikki in
charge your bad but um what sure whose
trailer did you go to hang out I went to
my trailer did anyone go to yours to
hang out yeah sure was that he's mostly
going between Carrie and my trailer that
was the party trailers no not John yes
did you hang out in your trailer or good
to go to also go to Carrie's uh no no I
didn't go scary straight I did it no
well I also go to visit my uncle Kenny
but he's a huge Star Wars fan and I I
mean he's so obsessed with swords and I
lost him I couldn't find him and I heard
all of this laughter coming out of
Carrie's trailer and I went in there and
he was there just with the dog with Gary
Fisher her dog uh just hanging out with
them
wait Tia what are you doing here get out
of there yeah so that was a fun place to
hang out okay hi Jim McQuarrie with geek
dad um the question I have as you may
know Star Wars is basically a religion
now several thousand military
personalities list their religious
affiliation as Jedi and there are lots
and lots of Star Wars weddings are you
the new cast members are you prepared to
ascend to the level of at least
sainthood and mr. Ford have you any
advice for them or is there any hope
that you could even tell them anything
that would help them deal with that I
you know I I think my advice is pretty
much limited to look both ways before
you cross the street
stuff like that solid advice yeah don't
you think but I'm not going to tell them
how to navigate this very personal space
of trying to figure out you know the
careers of things careers that they've
chosen for themselves it's a it's it is
but bizarrely individual how you
navigate the space between where they're
at now and the rest of your useful
professional life but they're in for a
big ride and and they know it I think I
hope you know it ya know CJ didn't have
a chance to answer their part of the
question did they no no I remember what
the question was I don't need it how are
you ready for sainthood for sainthood
yeah I don't know if I'm ready for this
whole thing I just know that I'm just in
it and it's gonna come out regardless
but it should be fun you'll let me sleep
on your couch is stuff go hey all right
I hardly know you
what best friends he's just saying that
this is for Gwendoline Christie were you
prepared for how Captain phasma became
kind of an instant sensation among fans
and as a second part to that do you
think that that position do possibly for
a really strong run at the Captain
Marvel role if if Marvel happens to
offer it I was very surprised and
heartened at the overwhelming response
to the character of Captain phasma but I
really felt that what Kathleen and JJ
and everyone who created at Star Wars
was I think JJ's been open about the
fact that he wanted to respect the
origins of the films and celebrate them
but to bring them into the modern day
and confirmation of that seemed to be to
me in this amazing character of Captain
phasma who is Star Wars first on-screen
female villain and more than that this
is a character who so far we have
related to do to her choices
due to her character and not due to the
way she has been made in flesh and
conventionally that is how we have
related to female characters so this to
me felt very progressive and the the
response from the audience and the fans
has been so celebratory it makes me me
think that this is what the kind of
thing people want to see people want to
see a more diverse reflection of society
and I feel incredibly privileged to play
that part if anyone else wants to offer
me any work then I am very grateful and
willing to listen
hi I have a question for Cathleen um
thank you for that tip bit about Jar Jar
but I wanted to ask I mean why would why
the unprecedented level of secrecy
around this film I've never covered a
film junket where the media couldn't see
the film in advance the cast seems
terrified of letting anything slip some
of them said they haven't even seen the
film so why did you go to those extremes
I think you know right from the
beginning we've respected the fans and
and the fans have really been the ones
focused around making sure that
everybody and anybody who walks into
this movie gets to be surprised we have
several things that surprise us anymore
when you walk in to see a movie it's all
told in the trailers it's it ends up
online way in advance and I think you
know that's something that
overwhelmingly I've even had people say
to me I don't want to read anything at
all so that they can get in to the
theater and actually have a pleasant
surprise so that that's really all
that's driving it and we've respected
that in all ways we can greater cultural
impact of the force awakens what what do
you hope it is um for me I I'm gonna be
honest I really don't care about the
black stormtrooper stuff I couldn't care
less
this is a movie about human beings about
wookies spaceships and Tie Fighters and
it has an undertone and a message of
courage and a message of friendship and
and loyalty and I think that's something
that is ultimately important I watched a
movie with Kathy just lost last week and
I really relate to Rey more than any of
the characters and to be in a
circumstance where you have to find
something bigger than who you are within
yourself is something that's
inspirational to me and I think that
people take that away in terms of the
kids or they're going to be
concentrating on his bb-8
I my questions for John and Oscar I know
you guys both reprise the roles for
Disney infinity 3.0 and I knew I know
you John our big fan of the series so I
was wondering was always it like to
reprise the roles for the game and was
there any time between finishing the
movie and and going back to those
characters with the game yeah I've had
to go back twice once once for Disney
infinity and the second times for
starters the right at Disneyland and
it's been to be a to be a playable
character I get to play with myself but
it's been amazing it was it was fun and
the characters in Disney infinity are
more of the childlike versions of the
characters in the movie so that was very
cool yeah I had never done anything like
that before so that was that was very
fun to be able to do yeah and it is it
is it's a slightly more energetic yeah
uh amped up childlike person and I'm in
charge now
no hi guys this is for the three
newcomers
I was curious how much of your
characters backstories you were told
ahead of time especially while you were
developing the characters and and how
that informed you know where you came in
with it I think this has been one of the
coolest things about working on this
with with JJ and with Lucasfilm is that
there's been a real sense of
collaboration with with that kind of
thing there is there's I was almost a
bit of a sandbox element of it you know
we could talk about those things and and
and and there was an evolution of the
characters from even from the first
meeting with JJ and Cathy and Larry to
what ended up on screen I mean for
example with me
I sort of talk after we'd started
filming I was talking a bit about you
know just kind of talking about where
poke could have been from and the thing
is in New Hope at the very end of New
Hope at the medal ceremony one of
Guatemala's claim to fame is that that
last shot where the ships are leaving
where you see the temples was shot in
Guatemala and and then for me the fact
that I was born there
and that's a rebel base and playing a
resistance fighter rebel fighter I
thought you know maybe po was there he
was you know that's where he's from and
then this comic book comes out called
shattered Empire where Poe's parents
ended up going to the oven the oven for
and making sweet love and and so so
that's an amazing thing is the first
time that you know talking about where a
character could have come from ends up
in a comic book and it's uh it's it's
kind of a it's a beautiful thing it
feels like we're creating these these
things together so yeah yeah I didn't
know much going in because obviously it
was over the spoilers and all that kind
of stuff but I having the sides which
were loosely based on on who Finn and
and and Rey was but I just remember
during my time screen testing I was like
- Daisy there's no way that our stories
are so simple and we still don't know so
I've still got some conspiracy theories
as a fan as to where Finn comes from and
I'm still trying to figure that out but
I like that it's a mystery I like that
your mind was similar I mean I was so
heartened that it was a genuine creative
experience to work with JJ about who the
character was and to develop that
together and really without horribly
ruining everything for everyone I think
it could be it's interesting to see
where my character may go
it is interesting isn't that interesting
interesting I'm interesting
you aren't at least George is it so hi
my question is for the newcomers you
three are obviously huge Star Wars fans
you talked about it many times I'm
wondering if you read any of the
theories online if you follow any of the
fan conversation and if so if you could
sort of say maybe what your favorite
rumor is that you've heard that you go
oh my god people are really saying this
people really think this is going on
quick good Jar Jar is kylo Ren favorite
I kind of wish that this go is true I
remember reading this the theory that
that Finn is Mace Windu's grandson or
something like that and I was at a party
and someone behind me just tapped me on
the salt on the shoulder just like yo
black Dada I turn around or Samuel
Jackson
he was gone I said that was a moment
that was a hyper front it's absolutely
impossible to follow what John has just
said ah and I have not I maybe I should
start I should start chant i i've not
followed any fan theories at all um I'm
just gonna say because I've been busy
with Game of Thrones whoo
it's Jon Snow alive or dead
I only weed my bits in the script I've
got no idea my questions are my
questions for mr. Ford how difficult was
it for you to slip back into the role
and how did you prepare to come back to
Han Solo and is it easier to originate a
role or was it easier to come back to
something familiar it seemed easy to
come back to the character clothes make
the man I had walked more than a mile in
those boots I was interested in the in
the the described path of the character
I thought there was an interesting bit
of business for the character to do and
I had been I've been having a real good
time with JJ Abrams talking about it and
and getting ready for the adventure of
filming so I was it was it was easy I
can attest to the fact that for all of
us that were there the second he walked
in to the Millennium Falcon and said his
first line he was Han Solo was back so
it was pretty instantaneous my question
is for mr. boyega um when you found out
you were gonna be using what appears to
be the Skywalker legacy lightsaber how
did that feel as an actor oh it it was I
was very excited to use that thing
because I think blue suits me and and
also it was it was amazing for me to
read your whole script and to find out
all the thing things that finn gets
do and for me it's like I feel like for
some reason did Jay Jane know what kind
of fan I was when it came to Star Wars
and write this role for me because I get
to wear a stormtrooper suit a rebel
jacket I have a a blaster I use a
lightsaber I hang out with frickin Han
Solo and Chewie it's just fantastic
did I leave you Harrison did you have
any concerns about being hacked off did
you have any concerns about getting a
limb hacked off I did I did because I
add my ver has a really long reach and
that's an idjit that's an issue but you
know I've done my Droid mayweather thing
just bob and weave um ask her I have a
question for you um because my mind goes
always towards romance and and and I
think that I was saying this in the
other one that um the reason why I love
Star Wars so much you know people don't
necessarily think of me and this fridge
is is that it has the parts there are
parts in it that are better than any
romantic comedy and parts and then
there's action movies buddy comedies
interspecies friendships everything you
would want but my question is I first
saw you in Romeo and Juliet in New York
and then I saw you and Carrie had such
acrimonious chemistry in Lou and Davis
and can you speak about any romance with
your character in this movie yeah I
think mostly with bb-8 inter-prison yeah
intro would you call that it yeah
there's haha that's there's some uh
there's a real warmth there and there's
a give-and-take and that's uh that's
who's got his back and now in that
x-wing Piniella is gonna ask you about
um athletes walk up songs which is a
song that an athlete will have when they
come out into an arena and Ronda Rousey
for example comes up to Joan Jett song
bad reputation did you have a like a
hook a walk-up song for your character
is this to me it seemed oh good lord
um
I'm trying to think of the name of it
because it's just coursing through my
brain now is that one that goes duh duh
duh duh duh duh duh duh duh no nose ever
yes what is it
Led Zeppelin yeah as me yeah trans man
exactly that that's a good one I walk
out song I don't even know I have to say
though that there was a moment on the
Falcon where Harrison you had the
blaster in your hand and you are trying
to skillfully put it in the host Hafsa
and Harrison was stood there damn it
damn it damn it
and me and Daisy were just behind the
camera just like this is freaking insane
right there but we had to do the scene
together and not a not freaked out
because it was like mesmerizing to see
Harrison in this environment in the
movies that we absolutely loved and it
was good to see you with with Chewie we
freaked out but we didn't show you
nothing we tried to keep it professional
for you thank you very much hey I have a
really simple question I wanted to know
um what were your favorite parts of the
original franchise movies and maybe how
do those like moments affect your
performances in the movies you're in now
uh my favorite part I think was when in
Return of the Jedi when Darth Vader's
helmet comes off and you see that he's
just a soft sad old vulnerable man
underneath
uh I don't know how that affected my
performance but that that's my that was
my favorite part
uh I just remember I was about six when
I saw the film and I remember being so
struck by the character of Princess Leia
and thinking even then in my infant mind
this seems different to the other women
I see in films I'm feeling very very
inspired by that and inspired by a woman
with such tenacity and being so strong
minded uh and I asked Carrie Fisher if I
said I felt like watching a performance
implanted a seed in my mind and Carrie
said that she did plant a seed actually
in my mind I assume you're not talking
about the scene in the in the snake
bikini sitting on Jabba the Hutt's lap
not that no no not that that's my
favorite
I remember Julie um audition it's not
from the original films but during the
audition I had screen tested and then I
heard that I was going to be brought
back one last time and mind you I had
been an audition for several several
months and I just needed inspiration and
I went on YouTube and I saw Harrison
Ford and Mark Hamill's original audition
tape just on YouTube and that really
inspired me to you know tap into the
Star Wars esque energy because I think
that's what that was something that we
were trying to take to gauge and that
really inspired me and I booked it
thanks Harrison he said right I think
that's it I think that's it thanks
everyone thank you guys
you